[російською] Тут вхід у одну з найдовших систем,
які поки що є в околицях Одеси.
[російською] У нас їх декілька, майже всі локальні,
[російською] хоча з цієї можна перейти в Усатово,
а звідти можна перейти під Одесу.
[російською] А тут — це один із таких достатньо
простих, загальнодоступних входів,
[російською] якщо є хоч якесь відчуття самозбереження,
то можна туди йти і гуляти.
[російською] Такої тиші, як тут,
немає ніде, вона тебе огортає, і ти — весь у цій тиші.
[російською] Якщо загасити світло,
то і такої темряви немає ніде.
[російською] Як би ти не закривався,
все одно чи в місті ти будеш, чи за містом — неважливо,
[російською] все одно місяць чи зірка дадуть хоч трохи світла.
[російською] А тут — повна темрява, і це дуже класно!
[російською] Це очищує тебе, звільняє від проблем,
і ти трохи ближче до землі стаєш.
[російською] Коли потужно вся ця справа розвивалась,
[російською] декілька спелеоклубів
прямо війни між собою влаштовували.
[російською] І тоді кожен любитель підземель,
що себе поважає,
[російською] повинен був мати якусь свою позначку,
яку він ставив на стіні.
[російською] І зараз хлопці вже подорослішали, приходять:
[російською] «О! Так це ж моя позначка!»
[російською] Ось теж чиясь мітка: AVF 96 рік.
[російською] Людей було багато, і зараз їх багато.
[російською] Інколи зустрічаєш під землею,
і перший раз взагалі їх бачиш,
[російською] хоча наче в одному напрямку всі рухаємось.
[російською] Метою 90 відсотків усіх цих підземель
було видобування каменю.
[російською] Є два типи: ручне і машинне добування.
[російською] При машинному добуванні
завжди рівні стіни, висока стеля.
[російською] Машин також є різних чотири види,
[російською] але одним із найстаріших видобувань є ручна.
[російською] Усе некондиційне каміння складають
або під стінами, або у небезпечних місцях.
[російською] Ось як тут. Оця би стіна
вже давно би впала, і не було б проходу,
[російською] якби хтось обережно тут не склав
оцю стіночку з проходом,
[російською] за рахунок якої уже
багато років ми можемо тут ходити.
[російською] Під самою Одесою
таких каменярень було небагато,
[російською] є досі робочі системи,
[російською] до цих днів люди ходять під землю
і випилюють це каміння.
[російською] Ну, правда, вручну вже давно ніхто не випилює,
[російською] всі виробляють виключно машиною.
[російською] Ну ось тут чітко видно як випилювалось каміння:
[російською] ось це все вручну пилою випилювалось
із однієї сторони, потім із іншої сторони,
[російською] зверху забивали ломи,
ось прямо видно, як вони заходять.
[російською] Випилили, виломали шматок,
потім його вже на підлозі подрібнили на каміння.
[російською] Ось — наступний, наступний, і ось так воно пішло.
[російською] Є люди, які шукають
саме щось історичне чи реліквії якісь,
[російською] для збільшення знань про місцевість.
[російською] За всіма даними саме тут було
партизанське сховище: тут знайшли зброю, одяг, набої.
[російською] Це було достатньо давно.
[російською] Але навіть років п'ять-сім тому,
[російською] при мені тут із металошукачем
знайшли сумку з патронами,
[російською] вони всі були встромлені
в цю стіну для сувенірів.
[російською] Ну практично за рік уся стіна розійшлась.
[російською] Шукали щось цікаве у своєму дитинстві,
я думаю, всі потроху.
[російською] Попався друг, який покликав.
[російською] А тут я зрозумів,
що почуваюся немов риба у воді:
[російською] легко бігаю, легко орієнтуюсь.
[російською] Зала «Хрещення».
[російською] Вона датована 1972 роком.
[російською] 30 липня, коли створювали залу,
тут був великий стіл на 150-200 людей.
[російською] Ми зараз практично ходимо по ньому.
Ось він пішов сюди.
[російською] Тут, до речі, вже є трохи води.
[російською] Ось місце знижується.
[російською] Тут завжди можна було
і посуд помити після застілля.
[російською] І тут само поруч уже і озеро.
[російською] Не всі, звісно, це розуміють.
[російською] Деякі не можуть прокинутись,
[російською] деякі не можуть
заснути в постійній темряві.
[російською] Складно розуміти
котра година на поверхні.
[російською] Навіть люди, у яких начебто чітко
налаштовані біоритми, біогодинник,
[російською] все одно тут збиваються
і не можуть відповісти котра зараз година.
[російською] Я тут можу ходити виключно
по своїй пам'яті, а не по картах.
[російською] Ну, в принципі, це неважко,
якщо дотримуватися незначних заходів безпеки.
[російською] Якщо ти ідеш під землю,
ти маєш сказати комусь, куди ти йдеш.
[російською] Це дуже важливе правило,
бо якщо тебе там завалить,
[російською] і ніхто про це не буде знати,
то тебе не почнуть шукати.
[російською] А так, якщо загубився,
і не знаєш куди йти,
[російською] і знаєш,
що тебе будуть шукати, то краще сиди.
[російською] Візьми камінь і бий ним по підлозі.
[російською] Такий ударний звук
поширюється дуже далеко, і чути його гарно.
[російською] Крики зовсім не чути.
[російською] Пориста структура гасить повністю все.
[російською] «І в молитві моїй, не заважай соловей...»
[російською] Ну це явно щось не із сучасного фольклору.
[російською] Це теж розчищали очевидно.
[російською] Бачиш, камінням було закладено.
[російською] Розчищали,
щоб дістатися до самої суті, до малюнку.
[російською] Хлопці ж для пам'яті зберігають все це.
[російською] Роблять фотографії,
прив'язують це все до карт підземелля,
[російською] потім це прив'язується до карти поверхні.
[російською] І дуже багато вже їх є.
Ну, звісно, це все приватні архіви.
[російською] Хлопці виїжджають компанією
в 10-15 людей на два-три дні,
[російською] і проводять топозйомку району.
[російською] Це у тебе планшетка така велика,
міліметровий папір,
[російською] рулетка на 30 чи 50 метрів,
декілька компасів.
[російською] Потім це все скидається на кальку.
[російською] Потім це все (не завжди)
переводиться в електронний вигляд,
[російською] хоча переважно
це все в паперовому вигляді.
[російською] Це нікому нецікаво, скажемо так,
[російською] крім отаких от ентузіастів, які беруться
і помалу прискіпливо це збирають.
[російською] Якось я тут гуляв, і зустрів компанію,
[російською] і я здивувався,
бо вся стіна була обмальована балонами,
[російською] а тут приходжу,
і вся стіна почищена.
[російською] Стало цікаво хто, що.
[російською] І тут зустрічаю людей із металевими щітками.
[російською] Люди просто
у свої вихідні дні спустились вниз,
[російською] їх 15 людей, рукавички, щітки,
[російською] і чистять стіни під землею в катакомбах.
[російською] Із одного боку, це виглядає дивно,
[російською] а з іншого боку —
потім заходиш, бачиш чисті, гарні стіни і радієш.
[російською] Більшість систем під містом
були пульповані ще в радянські часи.
[російською] Тому що все одно потроху зсувалося.
[російською] Як тільки десь будується новий мікрорайон,
[російською] і є ймовірність,
що знизу будуть порожнини,
[російською] і не важливо що це:
виробітка, системи чи шахти,
[російською] то, власне кажучи, є окрема бригада,
[російською] вони приїжджають,
пробурюють свердловини,
[російською] потім туди спускаються люди на мотузках,
[російською] перевіряють чи немає порожнин.
[російською] Якщо знаходять порожнини,
то відповідно їх обстежують,
[російською] роблять топозйомку,
роблять карту, а далі вони пульпуються.
[російською] Пульпування — це коли шланг
із водою спускається в цю свердловину,
[російською] і потім засипається пісок.
[російською] Ну тільки це в промислових масштабах:
[російською] цистерни заливають туди воду,
[російською] КамАЗами засипається пісок,
[російською] і вода, немов транспорт,
доставляє цей пісок у найвіддаленіші куточки, замиває його.
[російською] І пульпується потроху,
по мірі будівництва нових будинків.
[російською] Падає, і багато падає.
[російською] Тут у нас була шикарна п
ідземна криниця  — так звана шахтарська.
[російською] О, до речі, оце от відносно
нещодавно впало, тут був вільний прохід.
[російською] Ух ти!
[російською] Далі все одно все руйнується,
все завалюється.
[російською] Але переважно
це все якось тихо відбувається,
[російською] тобто роки йдуть,
ходиш-ходиш, раз, і помічаєш,
[російською] що тут було нормальне місце,
а зараз завалився район.
[російською] Звісно, з одного боку сумно стає,
[російською] що природа потроху забирає у тебе те,
[російською] де ти можеш почуватися вовком-одинаком:
[російською] ходиш, ні від кого не залежиш, робиш, що хочеш.